I'm really excited in Campinas I'm very
excited to eat penis okay I've never
seen a penis shaped like this so would
this feet that little holes in them look
like a necklace what oh wait this is a
penis
that's the urethra that is like a
guillotine de penis right there
this is long ways yeah it's like that
like that
it tastes like regular dick I feel like
I'm trying an eraser it's like gum
I guess seriously almost like blow a
bubble with this dick it's weird to say
but it tastes like pee you're kidding
that's a testicle it smells sweaty it's
just got the skin of a wrinkled ball it
just looks like a ball
it looks like meatloaf from hell oh it's
warm which is worse there's like like
little beads there's little beads in it
it's really strong oh it's like hearing
inside it's not semen right there oh my
god there's strings oh my god oh my god
when you open it
can you guys drumroll please dick dick
dick dick dick dick dick dick dick dick
dick balls oh this one's still in the
bag little veins on it
oh now it looks like a real ball like a
real human ball as an owner of a set of
balls I mean I feel like I know what
balls feel like this feels like balls so
an earlobe that grew a tumor don't say
anything
this skin is so good I mean yeah but the
middle part is the same shitty bombing
exactly of course it is all balls face
bad
it's a big ball for a goat good prize go
to big balls I'm bigger than a goat and
my ball is not that big
oh it looks delicious no bad it's not
bad that's not bad at all I can't eat
this is it possible that I'm saying it
like this hey I'm kind of starting to
like it too like you're trapped on a
farm I'm like you know you already ate
all the good animals little pate put a
little crimp it on cracker no no one
will never know either like this tastes
like pate it's still looks terrible but
I want to eat it now and I don't know if
that's like the sperm affecting my brain
sperm heavy evil today answer me that
how much God it smells like if you left
tuna fish outside in the Sun mm-hmm and
then you know filled it with sperm